i want to ask you a little bit about
rupaul's drag race all-stars how do you
feel about the rating success of the
show and seeing all the queens come back
it's pretty amazing i mean when you
think of shows that only get better over
time and the audience only ever grows
and it never wavers drag race is out
here doing what the other girls
should've did i mean what's when you
count all the franchises and all the
all-star seasons they're probably on
season 25 or something
and it only gets better the drag gets
better the storytelling gets better
i mean behind and in front of the camera
it's diverse it's people of color it's
queer people it's trans people it's
it's pretty amazing and it just goes to
show that when you have a great product
and great execution the show has no
excuse not to be great
could we see you do another all winter
season i mean i would love to do like a
vanna white moment where maybe the check
they win i get to walk it out and show
it okay but you know competition has
never really brought out the best in me
queens of the universe has been renewed
can we look forward to having you back
as a judge on that series
i hope so okay i can either confirm nor
deny
i'll say this okay i
loved judging queen of the universe okay
every day my jaw was on the floor the
singing these are some of the most
amazing singers in the world and they do
it in a wig and heels it's like
unbelievable the singing on that is just
unbelievable so i hope i get to come
judge again because i i really felt like
i helped them does judging bring out the
best in you yes okay judgment just
judging others just comes naturally to
me maybe that was my problem on drag
race i should have been on the table i
mean you know judging
welcome to the trixie motel
oh the service here is amazing and so
pretty
[Music]
yes we're newly renovated you want to
stay the night
at your service
how does it feel trixie motel uh well it
feels great um however it's been such a
process it feels like
it feels like i had a baby in me for 18
months wow which means i finally gave
birth to a one-year-old child
so motherhood's been tough i mean so you
are intimately involved with this show
with trixie motel how much of a dream
come true was this for you well it was
really like a dream that you have over a
glass of white wine but you know david
and i drink a lot of wine so it was a
recurring dream you've been dreaming
about it yeah it really is a dream i
mean i've gotten to do a lot of cool
things as trixie but something like
owning a motel i mean and then being
able to document this as a series it's
like having the scrapbook of the most
stressful thing you've ever done
was this because you've been on some
endeavors yes it was stressful to be
honest like i was just last weekend we
were out performing for what 4 000
people and i wasn't
nervous at all but then you know i'm
renovating with a hammer like oh i hope
this looks okay so renovating is a lot
harder than comedy performing tap
dancing i mean anything else i've done
pales in comparison to the financial
stress and the the stakes i mean the
whole world's eyes are on this project
so the design has to be fierce and the
execution
you know it's even a play off your name
trixie mattel trixie motel so do you
feel that this motel had to be you in
every way it really had to be exactly
trixie but the balance would have been
how big and can we go with this but
still have it be not assaulting
you know like me like big inflated but
still like easy on the eyes
and i guess we tried to find that
balance of you know with our designer
danny who's really like the queen of
maximalism how can you introduce as many
patterns and colors and textures in a
way that feels like one
gesture in an elegant way
and uh we're only on you know a few
episodes in but spoiler alert i mean
this this motel is the most beautiful
place in the world for people who
haven't gotten to see it yet how would
you just describe the show to them what
do they need to tune in for
well trixie mattel me um i purchased a
motel in the desert with my partner
david and
we are renovating it into the trixie
motel which will be a kind of retro pink
60s desert paradise
but we're on a limited budget and it all
had to happen in four months before i
went on my world tour so the clock was
ticking i mean
it wasn't just like the the time i mean
people take a year to renovate their
living room and then they get a divorce
so for me and my partner to stay in love
on television and renovate an entire
commercial property
i mean
every day we had to both freak out and
then give ourselves permission to freak
out because we're doing something insane
give me some more of the numbers so four
months four months budget of the
property was 1.9 million dollars and the
budget was half a million dollars so
that comes out to about 2.4 and believe
me uh that sounds like a lot of money
but it really isn't in palm springs
that is not a lot of money i mean half a
million dollars is a great budget for
your living room or your lanai where you
want to eat cheesecake with your elderly
roommates
but like
for a commercial property where every
room is different yeah i mean if we had
done seven rooms that were a consistent
design that would have been a much more
handsome number but seven rooms with
custom wallpapers custom linens i hope
no one breaks anything because
everything in these rooms is one of a
kind well you mentioned you and david so
you fought every day you made up every
day what did you learn about your
partnership and what did it change about
your partnership maybe to go through
this together when it becomes your
business your lives your trust in each
other that word partner becomes a lot
more three-dimensional
because you're not just in love or
whatever that's easy when you introduce
this new stress and this new dream
together
now you're trying to like it's like our
baby really so it really puts your
relationship to the test but i mean i
came out of it being
more in love with him than ever
so you say in the premiere this is real
so are you running this motel how
involved are you gonna be and what is
the future of the motel we open in the
fall and so we'll be doing hiring i mean
we have to set up things like the drink
menu
um hiring staff throwing events so
finishing the motel was really the end
of the first chapter so it was hard to
necessarily collapse and celebrate
because i was like all right now the
real work is starting oh you're gonna
have some fun cocktails on that menu oh
beautiful strong probably some fun
little straw oh have you brainstormed
for the names i can't wait to see what
you mean the drinks well it's hard for
me to pare the list down when i love to
drink so much i'm like i think 50 drinks
on a menu is fine and everyone's like
that's a little far i'm like people need
variety so you just said that this idea
to do the motel came when you guys were
drinking wine
if you love to drink that much what
other ideas are next what other dreams
are happening over time a distillery a
winery no
but i guess my next dream would be to do
another motel okay or a campground
yes imagine you're an adult you go with
your friends to a cabin that's decorated
and the camp counselors are drag queens
with whistles and you're like day
drinking doing friendship bracelets and
canoeing i mean
if i've learned anything from drag
people just love an opportunity to feel
like a kid for a second
i would love to do an airstream trailer
like a trailer park i'm from a trailer
park and i think that they're
i think they've never had their moment i
think they need to have their moment so
this this home renovation show is the
first time for you how would you compare
the nerves of doing this show for the
first time to when you were first on
drag race
drag race is worse is it yes drivers is
much worse i'm not going to pretend that
you know at least with renovation you
can make mistakes as you go in a
competition environment there are no
mistakes there are there's doing well
and there's packing your bags
um luckily at the motel
there's many processes and renovation
where it was pivoting so this isn't
going well what do we do now
this isn't working so pivoting is kind
of the key yeah you know in in a drag
competition if you try to pivot you you
get eliminated we see celebrities like
lisa vanderpump she makes an appearance
right off the bat episode one who else
can you tease is going to show up for
the season and what did it mean for you
to have those people show up
well on a tv producer level i wanted to
have as many of my famous friends as
possible on a personal level this is a
huge project and i need help
so we've had i mean uh most of the
guests have been announced i think so we
have lisa vanderpump we have orville
pack iggy azalea's in this season i mean
very gay paint nicole byer
mohart the list goes on i think in eight
episodes we have 17 celebrity guests i'm
not even the star of this yeah at this
point it's just my famous friends and
then me being annoying
but it was funny because all the
celebrity guests are used to getting in
full hair and makeup and then just
sitting around and they got to the motel
and they're like so what do we do i'm
like here's your paint roller this is
what we're doing and they're like what
we really do this and like we really do
this putting you right to work yes so
everybody i think they thought they were
gonna get to like day drink and like
laugh and i was like no this is labor no
as you said this is real yeah this is
real i want to get back to uh to david a
little bit what was it like for you guys
to be on camera together that much was
that new and interesting for you well
anybody who's followed me knows that
we've been together almost six years and
i never tag him i never post pictures of
him he did my documentary he was never
featured on camera
i keep my relationship very private
and when i pitched the show it was just
me and then people became very
interested in david in the storytelling
room because
let's be honest somebody who doesn't
want to be on television is always
interesting on television david has no
ambitions to like be on camera be a
famous person
and i think it has a grounding energy
because you have not thought out right
i'm like obnoxious look at me look at me
and he just has a very calm
normal human being energy
and he's like compassionate and smart
and i'm selfish and stupid and you know
it's a good balance what about for you
to be brian on camera so much how did
that feel
i'm always embarrassed to be on camera
out of drag it makes me uncomfortable
yeah but in the ball springs heat six
hours into the day i was like get the
makeup wipe i mean we gotta just strip
give me the shorts give me the tommy
bahamas get me the mr turk you know let
me have flip-flops on and you have to
admit i'm you know a caucasian involved
in sweating i look like i belong in palm
springs i mean
you know i look like i'm the age group
of the people who live there
but uh you know it's always a little
weird and embarrassing but
um this show is more personal than my
drag life it's my real money for my real
bank account trixie doesn't have social
security number you know if i have to go
to the bank i have to go out of drag so
this is like a real a real gamble can
they see you potentially drop into the
motel on occasion maybe a surprise
appearance yes my hope and dream is that
i appear often and i never say when so
like 9 00 am you wake up hungover who's
that bald man djing by the pool oh my
god or imagine me knocking housekeeping
and drag and then coming and clean the
room just vacuuming yeah or maybe you go
get a drink at happy hour and i'm back
there i just think it'd be fun to
integrate in a way that's not
necessarily advertised totally you have
a story that you were there and you just
saw me in the pool and you're like whoa
okay
yes so much more memorable yes
[Music]
you